Speaker 1: Hey, this is sort of like an exercise
in humiliating futility.
Remember the truckers?
These these right wing truckers who are going
to.
Protest mandates and demand liberty and all
these things.
One of the leaders of the right wing truckers
has been arrested and he was arrested because
he came to the attention of police while protesting
non-existent COVID mandates.
You might be saying, wait a second, David,
the truckers aren't still going, are they?
Because there's no more there's no mandates.
There's some industries have requirement.
But like what what are we even talking about?
When we say COVID mandates, things are essentially
back to normal.
It would be really dumb to get yourself arrested
during a protest for something that's not
even worthy of protest anymore.
That's exactly what this guy did.
Our friend Zachary Patricio from Daily Beast
Beast wrote this article Right Wing Truckers
Leader Gets Arrested While Protesting Non-existent
COVID Mandates in DC.
Here is a picture of David Santa Rydell.
If you're looking at the picture, you might
understand why his nickname is Santa.
The leader of the right wing and COVID anti-vax
1776 Restoration Movement, former formerly
called the People's Convoy, was arrested near
the National Mall on Wednesday after his group
came to town protesting non-existent mandates.
Far right proud boy member and leader David
Santa Rydell was taken into custody for a
warrant out of Maryland.
Per D.C.
Metro Police officers, he was placed under
arrest for the arrest warrant that he had
issued for him.
If there is a warrant out for your arrest,
maybe it's not a good idea to get even more
people paying attention to you.
And I guess Rydell asked police to brief cameras
about what is happening and they explained
what's going on.
This is like adding insult to injury.
You're protesting something that doesn't even
exist.
And it turns out he was wanted.
And now you get yourself arrested.
Speaker 2: What did he do?
You're a disgrace to America.
That's what you are is a disgrace to America.
That's what you are.
And that's what you are.
Can I speak for a second?
Sure.
I spoke with David over here and he said it's
okay for me to share that information with
you.
Obviously, there's probably Dick there and
he's okay with that.
He's been placed under arrest.
He asked me to let you know because he has
a warrant for his arrest out of the state
of Maryland for obstructing the roadway, metro
blocking the roadway.
And Metropolitan Police was made aware of
this arrest warrant.
Therefore, we have to take action and excuse
the war.
Speaker 1: By the way, this officer sounds
almost apologetic.
I don't know if you are getting the same vibes
as me, but it's sort of strange.
Speaker 2: You're not even in Maryland.
You're not even part of the state.
Speaker 1: Oh, that is brilliant.
You're not even in Maryland and Washington,
D.C. isn't even part of the states.
So arrest warrants are interstate and then
extradition from one state to another is sort
of like the next step in a separate thing.
But there's really nothing super controversial
outside of these fringe movements about the
fact that warrants are valid across state
lines.
Speaker 2: And here you're you're here till
he has a bunch of constitutional breaking
powers.
Speaker 1: There's nothing unconstitutional
about acting on a warrant from a different
state.
Completely uncontroversial.
Speaker 2: He's out.
We're here till he's gone.
You say you want to the system.
Okay, so just.
Just so you understand how this works against
the warrants inside the state of Maryland.
And you will have I want you to think, okay,
I can't stop you for like 5 minutes down the
road.
Say, Oh, you are a coward.
Speaker 1: It seems like the officer being
called a coward for following the law is explaining
that, yes, the warrant is for Maryland, but
he would now be extradited.
And remember this.
This guy is only here because he's the arrestee,
because he was protesting COVID mandates,
which don't exist.
Speaker 2: You are a coward.
First Amendment protected speech for me to
call for whatever violations occur in the
state of Maryland on apparently July 4th or
fifth, a warrant was issued by a judge in
Maryland for this individual's arrest.
Therefore, we were notified.
This ward is extraditable.
He is here.
We are aware of it.
Yes, that means we have we placed him under
arrest.
So going from a judge here.
Speaker 1: Imagine after having to explain
such simple things to these people, such simple,
uncontroversial things.
Speaker 2: He'll be extradited back to the
state of Maryland to face those charges.
Okay.
So he will not be staying here in D.C.
Eventually he will go back to Maryland in
front of the judge initially.
So to go so he will be processed here today
in the city.
He will go to a judge here depending on how
the process works.
If he wishes to waive or not waive extradition,
then he will go to Maryland and see a judge
in Maryland.
Okay.
That's how the process works.
That's very much.
Speaker 1: Man.
What what a nightmare.
I don't even know at this point what these
groups are trying to achieve because the mandates
are gone there to defeat the mandates.
What mandates are you talking about?
Is it a grift for donations?
And if so, who's even?
Giving to these obvious scams.
I truly don't get it, but really a self inflicted
self-inflicted humiliation.
Arrested while protesting mandates that do
not exist